people people [music] who have studied
the doctrine and theological beliefs of
the Adventists much deeper than just
Sabbath. When you when you investigate
this, no pun [music] intended, it it it
it really is very very troublesome
doctrine [music] for me personally and
should be for any Christian.
>> Adventists go to church on Saturday, not
Sunday. Now, there's nothing wrong with
that in of itself as Paul says in Romans
14. But the problem is that the SDA
church thinks that the Sabbath is
binding on a Christian today [music]
because it's found in the Ten
Commandments in the law of Moses. But
the New Testament makes clear that
Christ fulfilled the law and that as
Christians, we're not under the law.
We're under the law of Christ. And the
instructions on how we are to live are
found in the New Testament.
>> Jesus fulfilled the law. Jesus became my
Sabbath. And I'm here to tell you, I
worship on the first day of the week
because of the GLORY OF THE
RESURRECTION. I AM NOT UNDER THE LAW OF
THE SABBATH. JESUS SAID there will come
a day, it doesn't matter when, AND IT
DOESN'T MATTER WHERE, BUT IT MATTERS WHO
YOU WILL WORSHIP. I'M TELLING YOU,
SATURDAY WORSHIP, as far as the law IS
CONCERNED, IS A DEMONIC DOCTRINE. Ellen
White [music] and SDAs do not understand
salvation. There's a lot of things being
said about the 7th Day Adventist Church.
Some say we're legalistic. Some say we
follow Ellen White more than the Bible.
Others call us a cult or say that we
believe only Adventists will be saved.
But are any of these accusations
actually true? That's what we're going
to discover in this video as I present
to you five myths about the 7th Day
Adventist Church.
But before I do that, if you enjoy my
videos and would like to support my
ministry, you can make a monthly pledge
or a one-time PayPal donation by
clicking on the QR code which you see on
the screen or the donate link in the
video description. Your support helps
keep my ministry going. God bless you.
Now, let's get into the myths. Number
one, SDAs are legalistic.
Many critics of the SDA church claim we
are legalistic because we place so much
of an emphasis on keeping the ten
commandments, including the Sabbath. But
even Jesus said in Matthew 5:1 17, "Do
not think that I came to destroy the law
or the prophets. I did not come to
destroy, but to fulfill." To fulfill
means to keep them completely and give
us an example, to follow. Even all the
way at the end of the Bible in the book
of Revelation
22:14,
Jesus said, "Blessed are those who do
his commandments that they may have
right to the tree of life and may enter
through the gates into the city." The
commandments are so important that Jesus
said they are a requirement to enter
into heaven. Now, this doesn't mean that
the commandments save us, but they do
prepare us for life in heaven. I mean,
think about it. If God lets someone into
heaven that lives contrary to his law,
they will spoil the atmosphere of heaven
and the sin problem will start all over
again. So Adventists are fully justified
in defending the Ten Commandments
because the New Testament makes it clear
over and over again that God wants
Christians to keep them. But Adventists
don't believe that keeping the law saves
us. Fundamental belief number 10 in the
SDA 28 fundamental belief states in
infinite love and mercy God made Christ
who knew no sin to be sin for us so that
in him we might be made the
righteousness of God led by the Holy
Spirit we sense our need acknowledge our
sinfulness repent of our transgressions
and exercise faith in Jesus as savior
and lord, substitute and example. This
saving faith comes through the divine
power of the word and is the gift of
God's grace. So just like Ephesians 2:es
8-10 tells us, we believe that salvation
comes by grace through faith in the
atoning sacrifice of Jesus Christ.
There's nothing we can do to add to
that. Our works don't play a part in
gaining salvation or anything like that.
But remember that James chapter 2 verse
26 tells us that faith without works is
dead. That means that genuine saving
faith will produce works of obedience.
So works are the result of salvation,
not the cause of salvation. Jesus said
in John 14:15, "If you love me, keep my
commandments." Therefore, when someone
is truly saved, they obey Jesus out of
love because they want to do the things
that please him. It's kind of like when
you're married, you do things that
please your spouse, like buy them some
flowers, watch the kids so they can take
a break, or don't eat all the pizza
before they get home. Not in order for
them to love you because they already
love you, but because you love them and
want to please them. But you know what
is really at the heart of the accusation
that Adventists are legalistic? It's
because most Christians don't want to
keep the Ten Commandments. At least not
all of them. And some Christians don't
want to keep any of them at all. And so
an easy way for them to dismiss
Adventists and their claims about
keeping the law is to say they're
legalistic. This is how they try to
justify their own disobedience. But
don't fall for it, friends. God's law is
nothing to play with. I like how
Ecclesiastes
12 13 to 14 puts it. Fear God and keep
his commandments. For this is the whole
duty of man. For God shall bring every
work into judgment with every secret
thing, whether it be good or whether it
be evil. Disobedience against God's law
brings judgment. And even though we're
not saved by our works, we will be
judged by them because they are the
evidence of our faith. Number two, SDAs
get their doctrines from Ellen White.
For those of you who may not know, Ellen
White was one of the founders of the 7th
Day Adventist Church. And we also
believe she had the gift of prophecy
that gave her spiritual authority for
comfort, guidance, instruction, and
correction in the church. But what's
just as important is the authority that
was not granted to her. And that is the
authority to invent new doctrines.
Contrary to popular belief, not one
single doctrine in the 7th Day Adventist
Church originated with Ellen White. For
example, the doctrine of the Sabbath was
endorsed by Joseph Bates. The concept of
a heavenly sanctuary was introduced by
Hyram Edson and conditional immortality
and soul sleep came from George Stores.
But ultimately these and other doctrines
of the Adventist church find their
origin in the Bible. SDA's believe that
the Bible is the standard of truth and
all our doctrines need to be confirmed
by scripture. Fundamental belief number
one states the holy scriptures are the
infallible revelation of his that is
God's will. They are the standard of
character, the test of experience, the
authoritative revealer of doctrines and
the trustworthy record of God's acts in
history. So even though God used these
men to influence the beliefs of the
Adventist church, everything they
proposed was compared to scripture and
only after it passed the test, often
through collective Bible study,
prayerful examination, and open
discussion among believers was it
accepted as doctrine. Number three, the
SDAs are a cult.
Just like the claim that SDAs are
legalistic, labeling them as a cult is
an easy way for critics of the SDA
church to dismiss them. Cults have a
variety of characteristics, but some of
the more notable ones include demanding
unquestionable allegiance to a human
leader, manipulation and abuse, and
isolating their members from outside
relationships. A perfect example of this
would be Jim Jones. Jim Jones was the
founder of the People's Temple, a
movement that began in the 1950s and
ended in tragedy in 1978
in Jonestown, Guyana. Over 900 people
died in what became known as the
Jonestown Massacre. One of the most
extreme examples of cult control in
modern history. Jones claimed divine
authority, going so far as to claim that
he was the reincarnation of Jesus and
God to his followers. Claims like this
among cult leaders are not uncommon.
Another thing about Jim Jones, which is
also common among cult leaders, is that
he undermined the word of God. Jim Jones
actually started out as a Christian
minister, but then later began claiming
that the Bible was flawed and unreliable
and that people should take his word
above scripture because he was the
reincarnation of Jesus Christ. He used
fear, sleep deprivation, and threats of
violence to control and manipulate his
followers and isolated them by moving
them to Jonestown, Guyana, where he
forced them to drink cyanide laced
Kool-Aid, which led to their death. 900
men, women, and children lost their
lives. Jim Jones was a truly evil man
and the epitome of a cult leader. Now,
there are no similarities between Jim
Jones and the people's temple movement
and the 7th Day Adventist Church. And
the SDA church does not display any
characteristics of a cult. People like
to say that because we hold Ellen White
in high regard because we believe she
had the gift of prophecy, but we don't
demand complete obedience to Ellen
White. Our ultimate allegiance is to
Jesus and his word. Another thing, some
people don't like the fact that SDAs
have a high standard of morality. We
encourage obedience to the Ten
Commandments and preach that victory
over sin is possible. And we also
discourage the use of harmful substances
like alcohol, tobacco, and stimulants.
But it seems like some Christians don't
want that. They enjoy their sinful
indulgences. So, they accuse the SDA
church of being a cult because they
don't like our high standards. Just look
at this comment someone left on my
YouTube community tab in response to my
post about the Ten Commandments. Jesus
fulfilled the law so we don't have to.
We are no longer under the law, but
under grace. I get comments from
supposed Christians like this all the
time and making it sound like grace is a
license to sin which can't be further
from the truth. Notice how Romans
chapter 6:es 1-2 puts it. What shall we
say then? Shall we continue in sin that
grace may abound? Certainly not. How
shall we who died to sin live any longer
in it? Grace doesn't abolish God's law.
Instead, it empowers us to live
according to it. Number four, SDAs
predicted Jesus's second coming.
You may have heard that in 1844,
Adventists predicted that Jesus would
return only to have that prediction
fail. But that is not really accurate.
The person who made that prediction was
named William Miller. And he was a
Baptist minister that led a movement
called the Millerite Movement. He never
became a member of the 7th Day Adventist
Church. Now, it is true that a small
group of people from his movement later
started the 7th Day Adventist Church,
but at the time William Miller made his
prediction, the SDA church was not even
in existence. It wasn't until around 20
years later in 1863 that the 7th Day
Adventist Church organized. And SDAs
today don't try to hide the fact that
William Miller was wrong about the event
that he predicted would happen in 1844,
the second coming of Jesus. However, we
also recognize that his calculation
about the date itself was biblical. It's
based on the 2300 day prophecy in Daniel
8:14, which states for 2,300
days, then the sanctuary shall be
cleansed. When you calculate this date
using the day for a year principle,
using the starting point of Ardiserxes
decree to restore and rebuild Jerusalem
in Daniel 9:2 and Ezra 7 12- 24, you
arrive at 1844. So the date is valid.
The problem is William Miller understood
the cleansing of the sanctuary to mean
the cleansing of the world by fire at
the second coming of Jesus. And that was
his mistake. It wasn't until later that
early Adventist believers discovered
this to mean the heavenly sanctuary and
that the cleansing of the sanctuary in
Daniel 8:14 referred to Christ's final
stage of atonement and the plan of
salvation symbolized by the day of
atonement in the earthly sanctuary. I
know I probably just created more
questions than I answered, but if you'd
like to know more about the 2300 day
prophecy along with many other
prophecies from the books of Daniel and
Revelation like the rise and identity of
the antichrist, the seven last plagues,
the mark of the beast, the second coming
of Jesus, and much more, check out the
Daniel and Revelation verse byvere
devotionals linked in the video
description. Also, in case you're
wondering, if the Millerite movement was
from God, how could God allow William
Miller to get the date of Christ's
return wrong? Well, first of all, God
has always worked through imperfect
people. During the Protestant
Reformation, there were many sincere
believers who recovered powerful
biblical truths, yet they still held on
to certain errors. Martin Luther
restored the truth of justification by
faith, but he did not understand
everything correctly. Other reformers
continued building on what he had
already discovered. Second, even the
disciples misunderstood prophecy. Jesus
plainly told them he would suffer and
die. Yet they expected him to establish
an earthly kingdom. The prophecy was
correct. The timing was correct. But
their understanding of the event was
wrong. So the existence of
misunderstandings does not mean God was
not leading. It simply shows that truth
is often clarified progressively as
believers continue studying scripture
and that is the case with 1844. We now
know better and have a clearer
understanding of its meaning. Number
five, only SDAs will go to heaven.
You don't know how many times I've heard
people accuse SDAs of claiming that only
they will go to heaven. This comes as a
result of the SDA church teaching that
they are the remnant church of
Revelation 12:1 17 which states, "And
the dragon was wroth with the woman and
went to make war with the remnant of her
seed which keep the commandments of God
and have the testimony of Jesus Christ."
This fits the SDA church because the SDA
church is one of the increasingly few
churches out there that teaches we need
to keep all of God's commandments,
including the Sabbath. And the testimony
of Jesus is identified as the spirit of
prophecy in Revelation 19:10, which is
another way of saying the gift of
prophecy by the Holy Spirit. The spirit
of prophecy was manifested in the life
and writings of Ellen White. Also, the
SDA church has the best understanding
when it comes to end time Bible
prophecy. There are so many unbiblical
and bizarre teachings out there promoted
by various churches about endtime
prophecy that it's enough to make your
head spin. But I find that the SDA
church's teachings on prophecy are very
balanced and biblical. And this is one
of the reasons I became a 7th Day
Adventist. I come from a Catholic
background which really doesn't teach
prophecy at all. And I went through a
transitional period in my life after
leaving the Catholic church as a result
of reading the Bible. And I was looking
for answers. And I was reading a lot of
literature from other churches that left
me feeling more confused after I read
it. And it wasn't until I came across
some literature from the Adventist
church that started making sense of it
all. But even though the Adventist
church teaches that it is the remnant
church from the book of Revelation, it
doesn't teach that only Adventists will
be saved. An online post entitled, "Do
7th Day Adventists believe only they
will go to heaven?" by ask
Adventistfriend.com
states, "Church membership, whether in
the 7th Day Adventist Church, Baptist
Church, or some other denomination,
doesn't determine whether we end up in
heaven. This is because our entry into
heaven depends on our relationship with
Jesus Christ. We believe in him and
receive from him the gift of eternal
life." So there are plenty of people
saved in other denominations. That's why
we shouldn't be too quick to judge
others even if they don't have the same
convictions that we do. Even if we are
right, they may not be where we are in
their understanding and their walk with
God. But God is working on them and he
knows their heart. And also, we all have
a lot to learn and there's plenty of
room for growth. And I'm speaking for
myself as well. So after examining these
five claims, what do we see? We see that
7th Day Adventists believe in salvation
by grace through faith in Jesus Christ
alone. We see that our doctrines are
tested by scripture, not invented by a
human leader. We see that we do not fit
the definition of a cult. We see that
the 1844 misunderstanding was about the
event, not the date. And we see that we
do not believe only Adventists will be
saved. Salvation belongs to Christ, not
a denomination. At the end of the day,
labels are easy. Investigation takes
effort. My encouragement to you is
simple. Don't just believe anything you
hear online. Open Google Maps and search
for an Adventist church near you. visit
it and see what we're all about for
yourself. You'll be glad you did. Click
on the screen to check out some more of
my videos. I have a lot of good
Christian videos which I'm sure you'll
enjoy if you liked this one. Also,
please like and share this video to help
spread God's word. Thank you for
watching and God bless